[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER: Hey, Ahmet.
AHMET ALP BALKAN: Hi, Martin.
What's going on?
MARTIN OMANDER: I built
a Cloud Run service,
and I noticed it's slower
for users in Australia
than for users in the US.
Could you help me fix that?
AHMET ALP BALKAN:
Sounds like you
might need to put your Cloud Run
services closer to your users.
I can show you how.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
My web application has a
sign-up form with a city field.
As the user types
into the city field,
they will get
autocomplete suggestions
from a Cloud Run service.
AHMET ALP BALKAN: That
sounds good, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER: And I
deployed the service
to the us-central1 region.
When I access it from my
house here in California,
I get response times between
70 and 80 milliseconds.
I'm pretty happy with that.
AHMET ALP BALKAN: But you're
saying this service is
slower for users in Australia?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
This is what happens
when I access
the service from a virtual
machine I set up in Sydney.
There.
You see here, the
responses are much slower--
just over 200 milliseconds.
Why is that happening, Ahmet?
AHMET ALP BALKAN: Right
now, your Cloud Run service
is running in us-central1, which
is in the Iowa data center.
People in Australia are so
much further away from Iowa
than you are, so naturally
their requests will take longer.
For many applications,
this is not a big deal.
If the response times you
just showed me are acceptable,
you can keep serving all
your users from one location.
But for some
interactive services,
like your autocomplete service,
every millisecond counts.
So your users in Australia
would see a better performance
if you could take this
autocomplete service closer
to them.
This means you need to
deploy the same Cloud Run
service to a Google data
center in Australia.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
That sounds great.
But how do I configure
my Cloud Run service
so I can route them to the
nearest Google data center?
AHMET ALP BALKAN:
You don't have to.
The Google Cloud
HTTPS Load Balancer
lets you use global anycast
IPs, meaning wherever
the user connects from,
they're routed to the nearest
Google data center, and then the
Cloud Load Balancer will route
the request to the
nearest Cloud Run service
that you have deployed.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
Let's do it.
But I'm an application
developer, not a network admin.
Are there any
instructions for this?
AHMET ALP BALKAN: Yes.
I just sent you the
link to a web page
that describes the process.
Basically, you have to
set up an IP address,
a TLS certificate, then
tie it all together
by creating a load balancer.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
Let's see-- pulling it up here.
It looks like it's just a
list of gcloud commands.
Looks like I can enter
the names of my services,
copy the commands, and then I
just run these in my terminal?
AHMET ALP BALKAN:
Yeah, that's right.
Also, you need to update the
DNS records for your domain name
from your registrar to send
the traffic to the IP address
that you just created.
It's all in the instructions.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cool.
I will run these gcloud commands
and update the DNS record.
It can take a while
for DNS to propagate.
See you back here in 30 minutes?
AHMET ALP BALKAN: Sounds good.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
We're back.
What now?
AHMET ALP BALKAN:
Let's first make
sure that you haven't broken
anything for your users
in the US.
Do you want to make a request?
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, yes.
Let's see.
Trying it out now from
here in California.
Ah.
There.
OK, good.
It's still working,
and it's still fast.
AHMET ALP BALKAN: Excellent.
Now, let's check if the
response time has improved
for your users in Australia.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
Pulling up the web page now.
Entering the first
letter of a city name.
Yeah, that's a lot faster.
Before, it was over
200 milliseconds.
Now, most of these
requests took less than 20.
And it shows here that
it's serving from a data
center in Australia.
But why is Sydney faster
than what I get from my house
here in California?
AHMET ALP BALKAN: Good question.
This is because the
nearest deployment
that you have right
now is in us-central1,
which is in Iowa data center.
You could deploy
this to us-west2,
which is in the Los
Angeles data center,
to get even better response
times from your home.
In fact, there are no
downsides to deploying
all available regions,
because you pay a fixed
price for the load balancer.
And since Cloud Run charges
you based on the requests,
there is no downside to
deploying your application
everywhere.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
So my current deployment
is working well
for users in the US and
in Australia right now.
But what happens if a user
is in another place-- let's
say Singapore?
I haven't deployed my
Cloud Run service there.
AHMET ALP BALKAN:
Google's load balancer
is smart enough to route them
to the closest Cloud Run service
that you have deployed
behind the load balancer.
Why don't you try it?
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
I set up a virtual
machine here in Singapore.
Let's see.
Opening the web page.
Oh, looks like they get just
over 100 milliseconds' response
time.
And here-- we can see the data
was served from the Cloud Run
service in Sydney.
AHMET ALP BALKAN: Nice.
And if you don't want to
run a lot of gcloud commands
to deploy this
application manually,
you can write a Terraform
module and easily
deploy your application
to all regions.
We'll put a link in the
description for that.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, cool.
But, Ahmet, what about
my users in Antarctica?
AHMET ALP BALKAN:
Ah, serious question.
Do you mean the researchers
and the penguins?
Maybe we'll get to it someday.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah,
yes, the penguins.
Everyone, thank you
so much for watching.
Please leave the
comments below and let
us know if there are
any other topics you'd
like us to discuss.
[MUSIC PLAYING]